[Music]
no it's 3am but let's not uh
let's not say anything stupid here we go
e45
we are playing traditional chess okay so
we actually might face a vienna knight
c3 we play knight f6 that's the
principled move
uh don't premium knight c6 precisely
because
knight f3 is not the only move in this
position
can we play into the game but yeah well
if you if he plays the vienna we'll play
the v unfortunately knight f3 forces
that forces us into the four knights
so we play knight c6
this should be five yeah so this is the
traditional four knights
and there are
many ways that black can handle the four
knights that there's honestly like
rotate the knight yeah there's a bunch
of moves here
the traditional move
uh is bishop out to c5 uh bishop b4 is
also an old-school line just symmetrical
four nights
but there is a line that i play
personally and it's not necessarily the
best line it is i think considered to be
the most principled though
and if you really want to learn e4 e5
properly then i feel like this move
should be your main line it's just like
the way to challenge the four knights
uh you know right off the bat and some
of you are indicating that's
uh bringing the knight to d4 straight
away
and if you've never seen this before
whoa daley randy with a nice raid thank
you if you've never seen this move
before it might seem very strange to you
know to move a piece twice in the
opening but if you look at this a little
bit more deeply and i'll talk about this
after the game like some of the theory
i'll show you what the main lines are
knight takes d4 unfortunately there is
one line that basically leads to a draw
and that's e5
let's see if our opponent knows it
but the fact that he's thinking after he
takes d4 tells me that he might not know
e5
okay
and he waited for me to say that and
there it is
yeah so e5 basically counter-attacks the
knight on f6 and leads to a mass trade
we we have no choice but to take the
knight
so i'm playing quite fast in the opening
because this is theory now
uh there is a big mistake that you can
make you might say wait a minute this is
a free pawn we can play c takes d2 check
and then play queen takes f6
and that looks like that looks like a
free pawn but unfortunately that gives
white too much development and you can
just take my word for that again i'll
show you the details after the game but
it's very important here to take on f6
straight away
yeah queen e2 monk s and castles rookie
one and we're just not fast enough
e takes uh d takes e3
all right so now
let me try to remember the theory this
is embarrassing but of course i myself
do not
i remember the move i'm pretty sure
it's bishop c5 i'm pretty sure it's
bishop c5 just attacking the pawn on f2
and preparing to castle
and after bishop c5 queen e2 check
unfortunately we get a queen trade but
guess what i know this is probably not
the most interesting but
i i really hope that in the speed when
we get a couple of these very boring
positions so that i can show you how i
try to actually win equal positions
it's not all about crushing people out
of the opening you also have to know
how to play boring positions as much as
that might not be the most fun thing so
let's play bishop c5
[Music]
you you got to know that if you want to
maximize your learning this is a very
important skill
it's not all just checks and attacks you
have to be creative and and and you know
if you want you know to learn you know
chess as quickly you know as quickly as
possible you know then you you you have
to
you have to learn you know how to play
these positions
and
okay so
after white castles if memory serves me
correctly
we should also castle we shouldn't dilly
dally because
obviously um obviously rookie one check
could be potentially nasty it could
force us to bring our bishop back to e7
we don't want that uh it goes without
saying that we don't want that
and i feel like we should castle here
unless there are any objections to that
yeah so one thing that we need to
monitor after castles white can play
bishop takes d7
but that just doesn't look dangerous to
me for a variety of reasons actually
there's some crazy complications there
bishop takes d7 rook d8
who can tell me a nasty little move that
white has there which we have to deal
with
after castle's rook d8 and i'm actually
trying to figure out her response to it
i don't remember this line
sadly
hmm
yeah queen h5
queen d1 to h5 attacking the bishop on
c5 and thereby unpinning the bishop on
d7
um and we might potentially end up down
upon
so after castles bishop takes d7 i i
feel like we have something though
into my intuition just kind of tells me
that
it's not scary because white's so
underdeveloped there
i
am not i don't believe that white that
that's dangerous we're just going to go
for it
and hey if white takes on d7 and he gets
away with it congratulations you know we
tip our hat well the problem with c6
that i have oh maybe c6 was correct
i was afraid of rookie one check there
but what what i didn't realize is that
after king f8 were actually threatening
to take on f2 so maybe rookie one is
impossible tactically
but it's fine let's see if if he takes
on d7 and gets away with it all right
congrats
you know what i'm saying
yes probably c6 was correct and probably
this is wrong but
it's fine we'll deal with it we'll cross
that bridge when we get there
yeah so jeet is going to is thinking
about it for sure
no i that's exactly my response bishop
takes d7 cannot possibly work but
unfortunately that kind of reasoning is
very dangerous because if you tell
yourself that
um
that's how you often miss particular
moves is you refuse to calculate them
because they look wrong
whether white takes only seven and then
if he does then of course we try to
deal with this problem
yes that's exactly right the reason i'm
not i'm keeping mum about it is because
there are actually some very complicated
tactics tactics after bishop takes d7 if
you're tactically alert one idea that
you should understand
is if our rook was on ea let's imagine
that a rook was on e8 here then bishop
takes d7 would would lead to checkmate
because after bishop takes d7 queen
takes d7 we have a very nice checkmating
tactic queen takes f2 check rook takes
f2 and rookie one mate because the rook
on f2 is going to be bin you should be
familiar with this pattern this is a
very very standard tactical pattern
so one idea one idea would be to take on
d7
and play rook a to d8 saying okay okay
we're going to chase the queen out of d7
and then we're going to have that tactic
but the problem is that the queen can
move to g4 and the bluff work the queen
can move to g4 what does that do that
defends the d1 square so the tactic
doesn't work anymore i'll talk a little
bit yeah exactly i'll talk a little bit
about what we would have done after
bishop takes d7 but a4 is com is a
pretty big relief
yeah now i think c6 is very natural so
there's a couple of things we can do we
can play d6 we can simply play d6
but if you want to be ambitious we can
also play c6 followed by d5
grabbing
grabbing space in the center and you
know driving a little wedge down white's
position i think both moves are fine i
don't really think one is better than
the other
um
i like c6 but there is a pretty subtle
positional reason that i probably would
prefer d6 but
in this game i see you guys want c6 so
we'll play it you want sushi you'll get
sushi
okay bishop d3 and just double checking
that there's no tactics associated with
bishop takes h7 the move d5 incidentally
actually defends from a nasty tactic
white was threatening queen h5 which
would have forked the bishop and the
pawn on h7 so this move intercepts
any potential queen h5 b4 wow
that looks wrong
the first my first reaction to a move
like this is that it weakens c3
tremendously and i also see this x-ray
so already in my mind tactical ideas are
starting to germinate
thank you doing the work
and i think a lot of you are probably
thinking at this point why can't we take
on c3 and attack the rook on a1 but
queen takes e3 is a blunder
who can tell me why queen takes c3 as a
blunder
yeah because why does the very simple
queen take c3 bishop c1 to d2
attacking the queen defending the rook
and most importantly x-ray defending the
b4 pawn
so i think we can modify this and do it
in a slightly different way we can play
bishop c5 takes b4
and then white well bishop g5 there
doesn't make as much sense
and after c takes before queen takes a1
i don't see any tactics there for white
we're not quite nicely developed but i
just don't see what white can do because
queen h5 there's always g6
so i think we can safely play bishop
takes before and again queen h5 here is
a move that you would check
uh but it doesn't do anything we just
play g6 with tempo and then we take on
c3
and that was just a very uh
drastic and you know sort of panicky
move by white who didn't consider
appropriately the drawbacks of that move
that makes sense
yeah and there we go we're already
better and now the rest should be a
matter of technique
the implications had not been considered
by white
tommy code of the queen and i in the
line that you're referencing earlier
that queen on h5 would have defended the
d1 square so the whole tactic with queen
takes f2 wouldn't have worked
yeah it's funny to me that as our
opponent is thinking i'll go on a little
diatribe i've noticed this with students
too like
people in 15 minute games often just
play instantly and i really don't get
the point of that if you're going to
play that quickly just play a
five-minute game
why are you playing 15-minute games to
to tell yourself that you're practicing
and then play instantly the entire
game i just don't don't fully understand
that
so okay bishop g5 so that's actually not
a bad move that's probably a good way to
cut white's losses and here we have a
choice
the the simple move is queen takes g5 c
takes before and like
for instance bishop f5 and okay we're up
a pawn and we develop our pieces we're
great we're chilling
the greedy option
is to take on c3 with the queen
but something about queen takes c3 is
giving me the heebie-jeebies i can't put
my finger on it but i think you can
relate it's the fact that we're so
underdeveloped and you know queen h5
creates a mate threat and after g6 queen
h4 white's threatening bishop f6
i really don't feel like it's necessary
to go down that route and if you turn on
the engine yeah probably queen takes e3
is best
uh but in this particular instance i
think it's important to play practically
and you often hear that word thrown
around right okay here black played
practically what does it mean
it means in many cases not making a move
even if you don't see exactly what's
wrong with it but you have a good sense
that
something might not be right with it
i don't see what white's refutation is
after queen takes e3 specifically but
i'm just sort of sensing that it leads
to complications which are totally
unnecessary we can take the extra pawn
and we're completely not risking that
seems to make more sense to me i hope
that logic makes sense
so we're just going to grab this bishop
and then we're going to go for
simplification eliminating white's only
remaining minor piece of bishop f5
bishop h3 there's queen f3 bishop h3 is
not effective because of queen f3 that's
a good question yeah i'm sorry that i
didn't mention bishop h3 here
comes very close to winning the exchange
unfortunately there's queen d1 f3
yeah yeah so that therefore we go for
exchanges
now one thing to all yeah so i was going
to say
normally you'd have to factor this in
here the queen has so many squares it
can go to where it still defends the
bishop that it's you know you don't
really need to check for this
yeah so queen f6 queen g6 either is fine
we're gonna play queen f6 so that we're
aiming at the rook and that we're aiming
at the d4 square on top of everything
else
uh queen g4 i don't like
queen g4 offers a queen trade and
actually that queen [ __ ] could have led
to trouble for black i'll show you after
the game
i'm gonna make a note of this
yeah if i were to nitpick i i don't like
uh 15 queen g4
i'm gonna write this down
okay queen d3
now
should we trade queens and this is a
very interesting very instructive
question
on the one hand
the rules of simplification tell you yes
you should absolutely trade queens and
get into a rook end game and then you
should play rook feat
so yeah we should probably trade the
simplest is probably to trade but i
would also argue that a move like queen
f6 here makes sense
as well we can play quinn f6 too
because our queen is very active white
has a bunch of weak pawns
and you could basically say i want to
keep the queens on the board because i
feel like it'll be easier to exploit the
weaknesses also the weakness of white
skin white's played f4 which greatly
raises the potential of various forks
you can understand like queen d4 check
and if white plays king h1 then there's
going to be back rank problems
but in this particular instance you know
we don't want to reinvent the wheel
on the other hand i'll i'll tell you
i'll be honest with you guys my
intuition is telling me that keeping the
queens is a better idea
i just don't love the idea of trading
queens and there's another reason why
if we trade queens white place c 2 takes
d3 and you might say well that's great
right white then has a weak d pawn but
there is a downside to that which is
that white can continue the minority
attack with b5 well i can try to put a
rook on c1 and then play b5 and can you
see how the c6 pawn is going to end up
under pretty serious pressure
and if you play c takes b5 then white
plays a takes b5 and then the a file
opens and before you know it you might
be out of pawns and white's rooks get
really really active there
so
as tempting as this looks
we're actually going to drop our queen
back to f6 i think this is a we'll check
with the computer afterward
but i think this is a good example of
where not automatically trading
is is not the worst idea in the world
so i'll explain this more there we go so
b5 now is just not scary because our
queen is anchoring the c61 we can allow
b take c6 i don't care about that we can
allow we take c6 we don't care because
our queen is doing a great job of
defending the base of the pawn chain
so
what i think we're going to do now is
play
rook um
rook fe-8
what i think we're going to do now is
play rook f8
and just get the rook into the game
thank you risky play 3.
yeah white is not playing badly this is
not going to be the easiest conversion
in the world
is c2 a weakness yes it's a it's a
long-term weakness it's not a weakness
that we can attack
immediately as you can understand right
we can't
up we literally can't access that pawn
uh probably in the next couple of moves
so we're going to keep an eye on it in
case we have a good opportunity to to
target it
for now our our goals are a little bit
different we're still not there yet
our goals are to create lift so a move
like g6 would be nice not h6 because the
queen is controlling the left square
so g6 i would like to play
i would also ideally like to double on
the e file and play rookie four
and rookie oh that's another weakening
move
that that move looks really bad
so we have a choice here we can create
loft right now but it seems to me that
like a higher priority is for us to grab
control of the e-file
i really want us to take control of the
e-file
and so the classic way to do that is to
plant the rook on a defended square
and i have a good example of that
actually that i was showing today
uh in a lesson and then we play rook a
to e8 and once we get control remember
if there's only one open file you want
to control that file because that's the
only artery that's the only trade route
right that's the only route to your
opponent's position
and so by controlling that file you know
it's like you're controlling the only
access to water you're going to be a
pretty pretty wealthy guy
why is g3 bad well it just weakens the
king right it it opens up more space
around white's king that can be
exploited in the event of an attack any
time you push pawns in front of your
king you weaken the king
and
considering the fact that we are
controlling the e file whoa
john white with 50.
goes on and on
judd white with 50 subs
sorry people on youtube i'm freaking out
today is a ridiculous stream thank you
judd white for the 50.
oh my lance he trying to distract me
from the speed run game i see how it is
i see how it is well no more this is all
i'm allowing you to do thank you so much
really appreciate it jude white
oh my god jesus stop it guys this is
crazy
you waited for a good moment
you found one
okay so
this is a mistake
how do you know it's a mistake remember
last time i was
ranting about the importance of
identifying contact between two pieces
any time
two of your pieces making contact with
your opponent's piece you should file
that away in your mental rolodex and
here queen is making contact with the
rook
which means that rook 88 is an
especially good move because rook takes
c4 would be a huge blunder because we
would have queen takes a one check as an
intermezzo and then we win the other
rook we take the other rook
and so this actually not only attacks
the rook but it puts white in a very
difficult situation
because it's unclear what to do we're
threatening the rook rook can't move
from the first rank
white does have a good defensive move
here i think white's only
good defense is to bring the king up and
defend the rook but that's not the
easiest move to find and i think we can
win another pawn there
windy too
that's another good move
okay
but but you can see that we're making a
lot of progress here we're controlling
the e-file now we're very close to
winning the game
and we have i think many many ways that
we can proceed in this position there
isn't one way that you can win this
position
i think it might be time to make some
lift i think this is a perfect time also
something i talked about last time
is luft isn't something you know you
need to identify a good moment to create
loft
and the reason i think it's good to
create it now is because in the event
that all of the rooks are traded you're
going to want to have some looks you're
not going to want to have to deal with
the headache of then having to suddenly
take the time and make a hole for your
king you want to eliminate that freaking
headache so
let's go g6 we can also go h6 it it
depends i like g6 in such positions just
because we might also use this to play
h5 and finish our architectural design
on the king side if you know what i mean
yeah queen e6 would have been an
alternate
probably maybe even better queen e6 now
that i think about it maybe we should
have played that because that actually
allows us to control the e file
completely first
because any pawn end game is winning and
then we probably should have made left
it's fine this is also good
this is also good i don't think there's
only one way here
isn't that weakening but why does
there's no pieces left on the board
oh but but now it occurs to me that
white can't even take on e4 so we can
play queen e6 on the next move it occurs
to me that rook takes e4 isn't even
possible another thing to notice here
almost any pawn end game is going to be
winning for black so we don't have to
worry about everything getting traded on
the e file now i think it's a great idea
to bring the queen back to e7 or e6
let's play queen e7
actually wait let me yeah yeah let's
play what he said why queen e7 and not
queen e6 it doesn't matter but i'm also
noticing that the queen can jump over to
c5 if necessary
if that makes sense and that could be a
nice no d e is also possible but it's
much more important to control the file
than to create a passer
okay bcbc
our opponent defending very respectably
why is the pawn on game winning well
virtually any pawn end game where you're
up upon is going to be winning
especially one where there's no
asymmetry and there's no potential for a
passer
from your opponent i will talk about the
pawn end game though after the game i
will show exactly why it's winning
so don't worry about that
here a very good defensive move would
actually be rook up to b4 attacking the
queen i'm currently looking for a
response to that
we can also just drop our queen back to
e7 there
we could have traded rooks oh no i don't
think we could have because we needed to
take the rogue i'm not sure where
wait no what do you mean of course we
couldn't take back of the rook our queen
was in front of the rook but that's why
we put the queen in front of the rook so
that we could control the file
and again guys i need to repeat what i
always say in such situations
very often you're asking why not this
movement on this move
chances are that it's also good in a
position that's this dominant there
isn't just going to be one okay probably
there's going to be just one computer
move but there's probably going to be
many ways to convert the position to
convert the advantage but don't worry
too much like oh daniel didn't play this
move i don't get it i'm panicking yeah
probably it was an alternate
in some cases in some cases maybe your
move was even better okay now there's
multiple options
again i wouldn't go for the queen trade
here the rook end game is not as easily
winning as it may appear
and i will talk about that after the
game but it's for a similar reason that
it wasn't that good earlier
so i think the most worthwhile plan is
actually to push our pawns we have upon
majority in the center
and one plan would involve simply
pushing these pawns as far as they go d4
c4 c5
uh c5 c4 d4 and then trying to create a
passer with the queen still on the board
because then we could use that password
to overwhelm the king
um so that would be
one approach to the position
and that's probably the principle line
we could start with d4
or we could start with c5 um
hmm
let's go
i don't know i feel like
i'm torn between c5 and e4 we could also
play a move like queen c4 and try to
pave the way for the rook infiltration
but let's start pushing let's start
pushing
yeah white is playing really well i mean
he's defending he's finding a
challenging defensive moves that's for
sure
uh rook b7 i was even thinking about
sacrificing the pawn and going c5
and going basically for checkmate at
some point because we've already some
genius thought to create luft damn girl
i think i know what to do after rook b7
we have i think we have a very
instructive idea there
i think after rook i'm really hoping
that white plays rook b7 because there i
think we have a super instructive
concept
was rookie seven to consider but rookie
seven would have allowed more counter
play than it would have stopped it would
have allowed a check on v8 which you
could argue is not dangerous because of
king g7 but
yeah rookie 7 would have been
interesting
could have been something to consider
yeah for sure
[Music]
if i were white i would actually try to
get a queen trade with queen d3 not i
mean that is a really high level move
king f2 will just keep pushing with c5
because we're not afraid of rookie one
because the pawn end game is lost
there is a lot to unpack in this end
game i'm really pumped that we're that
we're playing it out because this is a
type of end game we haven't had yet
and i can really flesh out some high
level ideas yeah after the game
i do have coffee yes
a6
i don't care i love it yeah so let's
just keep pushing i don't care he's
gonna go rook b7 but we have something
planned for that
okay
so
first of all you should ask the sam say
your instinct should be to ignore the
threat
and let me think about how we want to do
this just give me a second to calculate
[Music]
there there there
there
there
yes i think this works there and there
there there
there's some concrete calculation to do
here for sure
yes i think it works
so i think that we need to keep pushing
and i'm going to make this move and then
i'm going to explain it
and i think that it's completely winning
i don't even think that this is close
it's not one of those things where you
are like risking and you have to go for
a super dangerous line that you might
have miscalculated no i think this is
like
overwhelmingly winning
i think this is overwhelmingly winning
although white is a really powerful
defensive move here which i didn't
really factor in but i don't think it
helps at all
white is a really really good attempt
here i won't say it until white plays it
you were thinking queen after but queen
f3 i didn't want rook back to b3
queen f3 i didn't want back to be throw
though maybe rookie two there would have
been winning as well
[Music]
he found it rook d7 okay now i need to
think
i might have gotten a little too cocky
here i'm going to admit admit admittedly
okay i need a calc now i need to
genuinely calculate
yeah i missed this move i completely
missed this move
okay i think i got it
i think i got it folks i think we need
to play c3
now admittedly i've made this
a lot closer than it should have been
a lot closer than it should have been
but kudos to our opponent for defending
well this is not entirely on me
okay so now what do we do
now what i was calculating is queen
takes c2
which is what we're going to do
now this is close to a draw but if i
calculate it correctly then we are
winning
if i calculated this correctly then we
are winning
white is a very strong move here which
is what i was calculating and he finds
it
okay now
i was trying to figure out if we have a
way of escaping perpetual
and i think that we do
and i think that we do
i think that we take on d8
then we go king up to g7 and we escape
the checks on h6
if that makes sense
does that make sense we sk we try to
escape the checks on h6
um a little maca s we can also try to
test them a little bit we can give a
couple of checks and try to return to e6
which would greatly ease the win but
um i think that taking on d8 is the
simplest
we can pre-move kg7
okay
this is close to a dry i admit i admit i
i allowed this to
to get too close
way too close
way way way way way too close
[Music]
but it's instructive that you know it's
never easy interesting
you know if i make these mistakes then
the people that you play
can also make these mistakes and it's
never over
well so what's the point here why why
did i calculate this our plan is to just
give a check and promote the pawn right
our plan is very easy the question is
not whether we can promote the bond we
can promote the damn pawn
that's not
up to up to debate what's up to debate
is whether white can make a move such
that even if we push the pawn to c2
white has some sort of inevitable
perpetual and i didn't see such a move
i did not see a way for white
to force
the um
you know to force to to to force that
oh queen e5 doesn't do anything it
doesn't threaten anything because the
check on g5 would just escape now we're
also threatening queen c1 and queen d2
trading queens the problem amazingly is
that even after queen c1 king f2 queen
d2 white actually trades and goes king
e2 and ch and and stops the pawn which
is ridiculous
but true
so we don't even want that we want queen
b1 check in c2 or queen c1 check in d2
and c2
yeah queen a7 doesn't work i think
because of queen d1 and c2 so our
opponent is thinking
on the manga s scale this is about a 6
out of 10
because i'm not confident that this is
totally winning but if my calculation
was correct then it is
does f5 lead to a perpetual i don't see
how
i don't see how although maybe it does i
mean
i don't think f5 works though
people on youtube that's exactly what i
said okay queen a7 but i don't think
this works
so
i don't think that we have a choice here
i think we have to move the queen with
check and then go c2
and unless i'm missing something obvious
there i think we just promote first
right white has to waste the tempo
to move the queen from a7 and while
white is wasting that tempo we promote
the pawn
does that
logic make sense
i don't think this works i think we can
just give a check
and the reason i'm giving queen d1 check
is because it gives us the most amount
of other checks if we need to give
another check to to drag white's king to
a certain square i think we're going to
be able to do that more easily with the
queen centralized than with the queen on
b1
hopefully that also makes sense
okay so after c2 my guess is that white
wants to play queen takes f7
and after c1 queen to give a check on f8
but our king escapes to h5 and then
potentially to g4 and i don't see a
single move there for white so let's go
for it c2
my guess is that our opponent is relying
on this move and it's really close c1
queen queen f8 is almost checkmate and
after king h5
queen c5 check would have led to a
perpetual if this newly minted queen
were not controlling that square
yep this is exactly i mean kudos to our
opponent he found
the most test one of the most testing
defenses but but it doesn't work we give
we promote to a queen
queen f8 check and king h5 escaping the
checks
and i can show you so many cool queen
end games that involve these random king
hunts that almost lead to checkmate
i even had a ridiculous game one time
where i had two queens on the board and
i almost allowed checkmate i'll show you
we'll go on a long detour after the game
and i'll show you some cool stuff
and just exploring these types of end
games can really really help you get the
hang of stuff
yeah queenie two check probably was
possible why why play with him when you
can just promote
now notice that queenie two check king
h3q5 check and then promoting would have
actually checkmated us due to queen f8
if our queen had been on h5 it would
have blocked the king's only escape
square
yeah so that's it the game is over
and there are studies like that where
you promote to two or three queens and
then you still get checkmated thank you
we think for the prime i mean the
substantive and crazy king h3 now the
rest is a matter of checkmating white
now
this
does win but it comes a little bit close
after king h4 but if you want to toy
with him a little bit wait let me see if
i can find something nice
the easiest of course is quinn h1 check
the easiest to squint h1 check
but if you want to be
slick
if you want to be slick then i feel like
we can play oh wait we also have queen
check that's another nice move let's
play the business-like move let's not
toy with him at all let's play queen h5
check then queen d2 check and ladder
checkmate on d1
listen listen
listen listen listen
yeah very cocky
well my cockiness almost cost me this
game so i learned my lesson
the computer is just going to laugh at
everything i did this game
okay there is a lot to unpack in this
game
yes
well this reminds me this one time
in in a way vikanze
uh i was playing johann harterson and
evan geller was
observing the game from a distance and
you know he was puffing on his cigar and
like he usually did
and
you know he had this very uh concerning
expression
uh on his face and i was just wondering
ephem i said to him after the game what
in the world were you so
nervous about and yafim told me that it
wasn't my game that he was nervous but
it was actually his game against the
alvin harterson
all right good game to our opponent
um and off we go
pay attention this is going to be fun
so
for night's defense you would never
think that the game would be interesting
now
again as i always say in the speed run
i'm going to live i'm going to leave the
opening exploring to you guys use
opening explorer use the leeches
database
uh explore this line with the engine
what i'll say is that the most popular
move according to the database
is i think bishop retreating to a4
i'm just going to give you a little bit
of history the first time that this move
was played
um
i wish we could do a poll
uh you know the poll would be like
before 1900 or after 1900
oh my god this is so cool i'm gonna nerd
out for a second here the first person
to play this
was actually the same guy this guy was
really impressive the same guy who
invented and first analyzed the king's
gambit line that i recommended in my
king's gaming video
the the shallow variation
emil shalom the german master this line
which he basically patented he was the
same guy who invented knight d4 he first
played it uh he was the one who first
played it in 1881
against uh none other than lewis palson
one of the strongest players of the day
and he lost that game
but still
uh he played it first
he played it first
and he was also the one who edited the
han book the shock spills the book that
i have back at home in san francisco
that like big green opening book that i
showed one of the first opening
encyclopedias that first came out in the
1800s she was the general editor of that
book so this was
the guy if you wanted to learn an
opening in the 1800s you would you would
contact him
you would contact him
um
so yeah if you wanted to learn theory he
was who you would write to
so he invented this move
and amazingly powerson played the main
move powerson correctly played bishop a4
which is the move that scores the best
and
in the old days people took the knight
on f3 here but recently
people uh understood that bishop c5 is
the best move and this is a pawn
sacrifice line after knight takes e5
castles you get some really really
interesting complications
black sacrifices upon for development
the main move here is knight back to d3
bishop b6 and black's compensation
consists of the fact that the bishop is
very hard to develop and black very
quickly tries to go d5 and bishop g4 so
i'll leave it to you guys to explore
this but 94 is the most principled move
our opponent goes for the most peaceful
line which just takes an e5
um and the first person to find this
idea
was let me check who was the first to
figure out that this basically leads to
a drop
in the year 1909 rosencrantz
wilh carl wilhelm rosenkranz uh was the
first to play this
and then cap alec alekhine was the
fourth person to play this
oh did you guys see if anybody follows
there's a twitter channel that posts
really old chess historical photos
and one of them was a photo it was a
video of alakine playing a move which i
never knew existed
it was a video of alakine actually
playing d4 knight f6 c4
and the video is absolutely hilarious
maybe i'll detour to show you guys
it was super super cool um and he makes
the funniest expression let me uh
go to twitter
which is really dangerous
so this is a guy named olympia de lupi
he is a chess historian and he posts a
lot of really really cool historical
photos you should follow him i'll
capture the twitter such that you can
see
his channel
you should see it in the center of your
skin this is alekhine playing c4
and look at what he does he looks at his
opponent like he just played a queen
sacrifice
like look at him um
look at him looking up at his opponent
like bro you just played d4 knight f64
get over yourself
like literally get over yourself look at
him
looking at his opponent gauging his
reaction like
so you just played c4
[Music]
like
i'm not sure that this is uh you know
this is not the game-winning move
okay let's analyze the game so
back to the moment where i went on this
entire
detour which was this one
um
so here we castled and i have good news
for everybody this is the main move so
apparently bishop takes d7 is not
particularly dangerous
and you all might remember that rook d8
allows this move queen h5
and white counter attacks the bishop on
c5
and the thing is you might say oh wait a
second we can play bishop takes f2
intermezzo and then we take on d7 and we
restore the material but unfortunately
rook takes f2 attacks the queen so you
have to bite the bullet and go down a
pawn but according to the opening
explorer apparently black is still okay
here because the bishop is really active
and white's extra pawn is really lame
it's just an extra double c bond and
with opposite color bishops i think
black is fine here
but apparently the main line is bishop
takes d7 queen takes d7 and now rook
rook 88 seems to score very very well
who can remind me what this threatens
who can remind me what this threatens
so let's say white plays a random move
queen takes f2 check and rookie one a
very important
pattern to remember
white can play bishop e3 but now after
takes takes queen b6 black restores the
material we're going to win back one of
the pawns and black is totally fine here
so
um
so
bishop takes d7 is not scary and the
main move here is actually queen h5
queen h5 d6 queen g5 which leads to a
queen trade and very likely a draw
so this line essentially is a take out
line which leads to a draw
um but our opponent played a very bad
well a4 is already weird
it allows us to grab control of the
center and now b4 is really really bad
which simply blunders upon
and let's fast forward to the first
instructive moment yeah so bishop g5
we we didn't take on c3 i think i
clearly explained
my reasoning behind that hopefully that
made sense
and after queen takes g5 cb
we play bishop f5 going for
simplifications f4 queen f6
takes takes uh queen g4 was proposed by
one person
what i didn't like about this move was
queen takes bishop takes and now f5
and the bishop is a little bit trapped
you can play f6 here and untrap it but
why allow this right
we will we will check the engine after
the game
after we analyze without the engine
so the first instructive moment was here
right
to reiterate what didn't i like about
trading queens well it's the fact that
white has this idea of pushing b5 and
creating pressure against the c6 pawn
now i don't know if this makes sense to
most people if you want me to sort of
make moves on the board but hopefully
you can see where i'm coming from
hopefully you can see where i'm coming
from
so for example let's say you go rookie
eight white plays king f2 to cover these
two squares
and let's say we play king f8 white
plays rook c1
um
this is a scenario that i was worried
about and white gets really really
active here now you can say after king
d6 black is still much better
and it's true which is why i said
trading queens is completely viable here
but i wanted to show everybody that
you don't always have to trade when
you're up material right and you
shouldn't you definitely shouldn't do it
automatically
and absolutely as ripple tempo says the
the fact that white played f4 is an
argument in favor of keeping the queens
because i thought that there is a
non-zero chance that we could get an
attack against the king which is now
weakened by this move
so b5 rookie a we can ignore b5 we go
rookie four slamming the rook into this
defended square
and
now
there's many options we decided to make
some luft
and then we decided to grab control of
the e file with queen e7 so we're
definitely winning now
and at this point a lot of you were
proposing the move queen e2 or queen e3
check again it's the same problem rook
end games are notorious for being hard
to win and after rook b7 i think you can
you can understand why i didn't go for
this we're losing the a pawn
and although you can win the c pawn in
return
what's gonna happen is that white's
gonna push the a pawn you're going to
have to stop it with your rook and
white's going to take the sea pawn which
is going to lead to a three-on-three
with a d-pawn that's definitely not easy
to win that actually might be a draw
that actually might be a draw so
trading queens is not a good idea here
trading quiz is not a good idea here
is a6 a good idea well yeah we could
have played a6 and slowed down the a
pawn but at this point i i came up with
this idea of pushing the pawns and i
decided not to delay with that so we go
z4
now
if rook b7 had happened we would have
gone c5
and after rook takes a7 i think there's
an incredibly powerful move here that
wins the game i'll give you guys a
chance to find it it's not c4
it's not c4 it's a very specific concept
papello thank you queen f3 very nice
good job
no but again guys you're making the same
mistake it's not a queen trade queen
trading queens is really bad here
because white already has a passer
queen f3
intending to infiltrate with the rook on
e2 and the fact that we made love here
is incredibly important
so for example rook c7 rookie 2 and
white has to give up the queen because
it's checkmate otherwise and the check
doesn't give anything due to king g7
um if white tries to play queen let's
say g2 then we give a check on d1
and we go rookie one it's completely
winning white cannot cover all of the
infiltration squares kind of an
important idea to know by the way this
idea of moving the queen to the side and
making room for the rook
i can probably find
examples of this exact idea if you gave
me some time but
you know i i think you you get the point
i think you get the point although i can
i can do a quick search and see what i
can find
yeah so basically it's this position
and in this position white plays you
might say it wasn't worth all the time
you waited white gives up the very nice
bishop for the very very nice knight for
the bat bishop and plays knight f6 check
and the point is just that this leads to
complete domination right this is the
notion of domination
you can't play queen f7 for exactly the
same reason
you can't play rook b8 because of rookie
7
but what is white actually threatening
who can tell me what white's threat
actually is let's say black waits with
the rook c7
and think of moves that just expand your
domination
this is not the easiest move to see
but it's very very strong
why not rookie 7 in the beginning we'll
see
not rook check that doesn't work
that doesn't work because the rook
defends g7 it's rook e6
very nice move and then you cannot stop
rook takes d6 or d because again rook c7
oh sorry there's rookie h you're right
rookie a check is just mate
yeah yeah that's what everybody meant
yeah rookie a check is just me
yeah so black played d5 and resigned
after c takes d5 because white just wins
simple enough right
all right back to the uh back to the
game
so
that's what i was hoping would happen
our opponent though demonstrated some
restraint and played a6 first and after
rook v7 c4
here again i was really hoping for rook
takes a7 when we have many many ways to
win
we can still play queen f3
although this is probably a little bit
more
complicated and here i calculated rook
d7
rookie 2 unfortunately here white can
con y can play queen takes e2 and a7
and this leads to unnecessary
complications although i calculated a
really nice line queen e8
and if rook b7 intending rook b8 we give
a check we drop the queen back when we
win the rook
but this is unnecessary and i think that
c3 is an easier win
because after white moves the queen we
go d3
and our passer is faster than whites
because we also have the idea of winning
white's queen check
and rookie 2.
and this wins
and this wins
so
this is easy rook d7 though completely
fell out of my field of vision
and i think it's very important that we
played c3 queen takes d4 and queen takes
c2
and again if white plays rook takes a7
then the win is very very well here
there's just checkmate on e1
but let's lead let's get this into the
end game just so i can show
the really interesting calculations
after king h6 let's say that white goes
with a neutral move such as queen e3
at first i was a little worried about
this because of the possibility of f5
jack and what i was trying to calculate
c2 probably wins here c2 probably wins
but i was trying to establish whether
this is a winning pawn end game
and there are some really interesting
complications here now at first you
might look at this and say well black is
obviously winning right because you go
king h5 and then you get your king into
white's pawns
but king h5 is a very
big mistake
it's a very big mistake who can tell me
why
because of h3
and white traps the king and you have to
go all the way back and you actually
might lose because white has the plan of
getting the king to c6
but what black can try to do here is
play g6 g5 carving out space so that
white can't keep the king blocked in
and essentially i still think it's a
draw because after fg king g5 i was
trying to calculate
who wins the pawn race here i was trying
to calculate he wins the pawn race
so you go down this path
and in this position it's crucial to
push the right pawn do you push the h
pawn or do you push the f pawn
who can tell me which one should be
pushed
it's the h1
it's the h bond let's test both so if
you push the f pawn which is what i
initially thought
essentially white has to put the king on
such a square that the queens cannot be
traded by force which is not this square
because here the queen can be skewered
with queen f8 then you trade and push
and not b7 because then the skewer
happens diagonally but the king goes to
b6
and after f2 a7 f1 a white has very good
drawing chances i think this might even
be a theoretical draw
so you don't push the f1 you push the h1
and the reason why
is because
you should know this concept the h-bond
simultaneously stops promotion
and obviously forces the queen straight
and now the f bomb goes and promotes
but let's go all the way back because as
we know long variation wrong variation
unfortunately white can still play the
move h3
and i was trying to evaluate this end
game i think black is still winning
though we go king f5
king takes d2 king e4
now we want to infiltrate so white has
to go king to and now we go back to d5
and ironically the a pawn which was
white's saving grace in other lines is
now white is now a sitting duck and is
now the reason that white loses we win
that pawn and then the rest is easy
so i want to check this with the
computer
but it's all unnecessary because after
king f2 i think the simple move c2 wins
the game i think the simple c2 wins the
game because f5 check is a paper tiger
we play g5 and white has no checks
and after h4 we play c1 queen look at
this queen takes g5 x-ray defense
and if hg our king escapes narrowly but
escapes the checks
so
really cool complications here i hope
everybody was able to follow this
and the way that the game went
we just had to calculate and make sure
that the king escapes the checks after
queen f8 which it does
and the rest is easy queen c5 our queen
defends that square which is incredibly
important
which is incredibly important
so let's test it now with the engine
which i don't like doing but
nonetheless i know everybody wants to
see how wrong i was
okay it was decent um
now let's go all the way this is all
book book book a4 is best wow the
computer does like a4
okay b4 is the player yeah so queen
queen d2 according to the engine and
probably intending queen g5 so b4 takes
bishop g5 takes yeah so what did i say i
said this was best but not by that much
not by that much and here we have to
play like an engine in order to get out
of this
you see what i'm saying
it doesn't change the evaluation that
much and it leads to a much safer
advantage okay bishop f5 apparently was
not preferred
by the engine and there we go queen f6
is best as you can see
the engine is not a huge fan of taking
on d3 which greatly reduces the
advantage
so i feel vindicated here
b5 rookie eight g3 or key four
or the eight g6 the engine doesn't love
oh yeah we could have just played c
takes b5a takes b5 and now queen b6
check we could have won a second pawn i
wasn't even thinking in that in that
direction
okay queen e7 this is all fine
d4 is best yeah so we found the right
idea hero pushing the pawns
c3 is an egg oh yeah we could have
played queen f3 here
i just didn't think of that queen f3
here
oh yeah that's winning rick d4 rookie
two
and after rogue d8 king g7 the king
escapes the checks much like it did in
the game
yeah g3 is a weakening move i mean not
only is it a weakening move it basically
loses weight the game here
[Music]
no but it helps very specifically the
fact that white play g3 allows us to see
this queen f3 move but c3 also wins
and let's see queen d4 king h6 so queen
c5 is best
and now we go queen d2
now the question is why don't we give a
check here and go king
f2 c2
oh this is probably queen f8 checking h5
h527
and all of a sudden light threatens
checkmate this leads to a lot of
complications
this leads to a lot of complications so
the best line here
is to go queen d2
and after queen fa checking h5 queen e7
our king actually has a pathway toward
f3
that's the idea i mean look at this and
the queen on d2 defends the d5 score
which is really important
so these end games are never easy
and black is winning here c2 is coming
white goes g4
which forces with which threatens
checkmate in one and forces us to take
the pawn and okay we're two pawns up
here this is obviously winning
but this was white's most resilient
defense so he took it
i just want to test whether the pawn end
game is in fact winning
so c2 here's the best let's check
oh it's a draw i was wrong
it is a draw so g5
oh king takes d2 why doesn't have to
take it
ah white doesn't have to take it
yeah king takes d2 is the move here and
after gfgf king h5
king d3 king g4 king e4 and apparently
this is a draw
because if king h3 the pawn race results
in equality amazing
the black king is in the way of the pawn
and this and the pawns promote
simultaneously and
it's a draw
and in the meantime if white goes f5
check
trying to
prepare for the pawn race not king d5
this loses but king e5
h5
and look at this h4
mutual zugswang takes takes king g5 king
g3 king g5 and again the pawns promote
simultaneously
and it's a draw
jesus you could also play h3 check there
you could also play
h3 check which is the same exact thing
takes takes
h4 king g5 knew g3 f5 draw
so
it's a good thing that this didn't
happen because i might have gone for the
pawn end game just to try to illustrate
that it's winning when in fact it's not
the move is c2 and the game is over
yeah there's so much to unpack here but
queen takes a7 is easy c2
c1
and
that's it we win the game
um
yeah that's about it that's about all i
have
and this is why analyzing with the
engine leaves you with more questions
than answers and that's exactly right
you the problem with analyzing with an
engine is that you first of all you
start feeling like
first of all the problem so for example
a trap that you might fall into
is thinking oh you know c3 is a big
mistake i should have seen queen f3 like
no c3 is fine
and another trap you might fall into is
is telling yourself oh bishop f5 was a
mistake
so the conclusion that you might draw is
that you shouldn't trade you shouldn't
simplify up upon which is not true
right so because the computer calls
certain things inaccurate you might
reach false conclusions on the basis of
it which is why you should always take
engine emails with a grain of salt and
if the eval doesn't change more than
what one point you can often disregard
inaccuracies like i don't consider
bishop f5 to be an inaccuracy in human
terms i don't know if that makes sense
but analyzing with an engine can be very
helpful
but you should remember that just
because the engine calls something a
mistake or an inaccuracy doesn't
necessarily mean that it indicates that
you have a weakness in that area or that
your move was actually that bad
um and that's why an engine does not
replace a coach a coach or at least a
good coach
will go through your games and not just
find mistakes that the engine
indicates but find moves that are more
revealing of what your actual weaknesses
are so what i sometimes do with a
student is
my student will say i'm sure you're mad
about this particular move
and i'll show him the game and i'll say
no i'm actually not mad about this
mistake this was a human mistake
what i'm mad about is this move that you
might not have considered to be a big
mistake but i think that the fact that
you didn't find the best move here
is not acceptable
right but the fact that you made a big
mistake there is a lot more acceptable
so
in order to diagnose someone's
weaknesses you don't just go through and
look at their biggest mistakes you go
through and look at their most revealing
and repetitive mistakes
all right that was a long speech but i
think you get the point
well in general you have to be very
careful about checkmates and queen end
games
you have to be extremely careful about
getting checkmated
by accident in an end game where it
seems like you're out of danger and one
of the most famous or actually this game
is not so famous but
one of my favorite and saddest examples
of this
is this game between
larson and paul karis
this is a good cautionary tale that you
can lose any position if you over press
yeah so basically larson is white he's
trying to press in this position
and
for a while they just go back and forth
charis doesn't budge it should be a draw
it's a four on three in the same flank
and they play and play play larson
almost checkmates and eventually larson
gets frustrated and
keras gets a trade of
blah blah blah larson decides to keep
the pont on f6 this is a draw but white
is playing and playing playing
and they're going out after it and he's
trying to get black in time pressure he
goes g4
and eventually he decides to get his
king
all the way to g5 he thinks it's a good
idea
to get his king to g5
believe it or not
this is a losing move this is a losing
move
and the reason why is incredibly deep
black is a brilliant move here it's
quiet but deadly some of my favorite
moves fall into this category
i'll give you guys a chance to find it
so not queen d6 not queen not queen d6
not pawn takes
queen g1 is very close it's the right
idea you want to pin this pawn
so
you do it from g3 queen g3
and here's the problem so first of all
let's understand why white can't move
the queen because if white moves the
queen and takes the his eyes off of the
e5 square it's checkmate
any move that doesn't defend e5 is made
now if you do defend e5 then you give up
the f3 pawn and again you could get
checkmated here
and f4 hangs the queen
and that's it there's just nothing that
white can do
queen c5 queen takes f3 larson played
queen e3
but now he allows h takes g4 and the
queen is pinned
queen f4 queen f3 thank you brizio and
after queen g4 karis uses the check
uses the maid threat
to force larsen
to give up his f1 and although white has
chances here he was obviously so
demoralized and saj that he ends up
losing the other pawn and losing the
game
so
not the
most memorable illustration but a good
one i think a good cautionary tale that
even the greats sometimes overpress in
such positions let me see what i can
find
okay liberzon against shuster oh both of
these are very strong players
liberalization is a gm
and chistikov was a i am
you can see that white is down
okay white is down currently
one pawn
but he gives up another one
and then another one
and then another one
he's down
three pawns and it doesn't matter
he his king is perfectly safe and here's
another one now he's done four pawns but
his king is able to escape the checks
and now queen b1 what an amazing move
stopping all of the key checks
and now back to b8 to prepare the
promotion
and again the king escapes
all the way and around to b4 beautiful
no more checks and white promotes
and of course this is easily winning no
matter how many pawns you have the queen
stops all of them
so in any case
[Music]